and then when she opened the car door
there was a hook hanging from it
what the hell that was the scariest
thing i've ever heard
i have one that's scarier
no way correct
no well what is it about
it's about a town
where no one was allowed
to twerk
oh like in footloose no in footloose no
one was allowed to dance in this town
people could dance they could do the
running man they could square dance they
could cabot's patch
but no matter how much they wanted to
they could
not twerk
so
in this place is lizzo still famous
yes she's more than just twerking yeah
you're right i'm sorry i said it yep
wait so
is there rap music yes but when you're
listening to rap music and the mood
strikes you you can't move the lower
half of your body at all
instead you have to twerk like this
[Applause]
of twerking normally people have to
twerk
like this
[Applause]
[Music]
the only thing you could do is
this clap those cheeks
this is the worst story i've ever heard
instead of being able to express
themselves through dance
they have to all be like
this
[Music]
my story was
scary terrifying it really makes you
appreciate what you have he certainly
does
hey corrine
what do you call a place like that a
place where no one knows how to twerk
correctly
connecticut
[Applause]
[Music]
you